I would argue that piracy is problematic
and I come at it from a very simple way
if you look at the music business pretty
much every piece of content in the world
is available legitimately whether it's
through itunes or Spotify anything else
all of which you have to pay some money
it's not a lot but it's some money and
yet still the amount of piracy out there
is is huge in the music business which
says to me that free can never you know
free always wins over something that
cost something the second problem I have
is that much of piracy is ad-supported
so Pirate Bay or most of the big pirate
sites are supported by advertising so
the history of the media business is
always that advertising was the support
for making content when Procter and
Gamble put money into making soap operas
it was literally to pay for the content
the advertising pay for the content the
problem with pirate bay or any of the
big pirate sites that take in millions
of dollars of advertising is none of
that money ever goes back into paying
for content so in that sense they're not
recirculating the money to build the
content economy and ultimately if all
the advertising money move from you know
legitimate to pirate then there would be
no content economy whatsoever whether we
can overcome that is really a matter of
decision on the part of advertisers do
they want to be on these pirate sites or
do they want to support Spotify to they
want to be supporting you know illegal
content or they want to
poorly were content and that that will
make the final decision